if you want to build a business that you
can eventually sell this video is for
you I've built and sold nine companies
the last one I sold was 46.2 million and
so I'm just drawing on my experience
from selling those to different partners
competitors private Equity strategic
buyers so that I can tell you the things
that I've learned so that you can get
there much faster than it took me there
was a guy who had uh rental events so
basically he started an event business
where he would he'd basically have a
venue that he would rent and uh you know
he'd have two three events a week there
and he would charge whatever the you
know the the day rate is for the event
and that would be more than what his
rent was and that was the entire
business and so he had three
locations he sold those and then he
started uh a coaching business or an
education business around helping other
people find event spaces rent them out
and do the same thing that he did right
and so he was like Hey I want to sell
this business the way that you sold gym
launch and after talking to him I was
like dude I think you're going about
this all wrong you're trying to sell the
Goose when you should be trying to sell
the eggs and this will be the common
theme throughout this is that most
people are trying to sell the goose
rather than sell the eggs and you never
want to sell the goose you want to keep
the goose and let it keep laying golden
eggs right so that you can keep selling
them and for those you who don't know
the story of the the goose and the
golden egg uh I'll read it to you it's 2
seconds there was once a countryman who
possessed the most wonderful Goose you
can imagine for every day when he
visited the nest the goose had laid a
beautiful glittering golden egg the
Countryman took the eggs to the market
and soon began to get rich but it was
not long before he grew impatient with
the goose because she only gave him one
egg a day he was not getting rich fast
enough then one day after he had
finished counting his money the idea
came to him that he could get all the
golden eggs at once by killing the goose
and cutting it open but when the deed
was done not a single golden egg did he
find and his precious Golden Goose was
dead there's something that creates
value and then there's the thing that is
valuable and so figuring out which of
the things that you have in your
business is the goose and which of them
is the eggs is one of the the highest
leverage things that you can do because
you can build towards the exit
intelligently and so in this business I
was like hey man you're getting all
these uh people on using your system
systems and your processes and your
price points I was like you're doing all
the work that a rollup would have to do
if they acquired a bunch of these
businesses I was except you're doing it
up front and so why don't you know this
ahead of time and say Hey I want to
build so that I can have the hundred or
500 or thousand of my students who are
using my system for doing event spaces I
should use all of those guys and I
should set it up ahead of time saying
hey use these colors and use these
systems and use these price points and
in the future if you're successful if
you're the top 10% of the students here
I have an opportunity where you can roll
up and sell with me in a group of 20 or
50 of these and so here's the thing if
that's the business model then you can
just roll up 20 to 50 every other year
and have a massive exit while you still
keep the goose that brings those people
in and the thing is is that the goose
often is incredibly valuable but not
sellable and that's what's that's the
difficult part about this right and I'll
give you a counter example so for me
acquisition. comom is my Goose right
like am I going to sell acquisition.
comom not really there are some things
that I'll talk about in a second about
like transactions you can have at the
goose level but what what really makes
sense for me it's for me to sell the
eggs it's for me to sell the subsidiar
it's for me to sell the companies that
acquisition. comom invests in right so
the big picture is understanding what is
your goose and what are your eggs so
I'll give you a different story so I had
a dude who uh who who saying he had a
couple Amazon stores you'll notice this
recurring theme had a couple Amazon
stores and he did well with those and
sold the Amazon stores and he started
teaching people how to sell you know to
start and build Amon Amazon stores and I
was like okay he's like so I want to
potentially sell this company I was like
well the thing is is that this business
isn't very recurring it's not very
sticky uh it has huge keyman risk with
you being the face of it like not a lot
of investors would a want to buy it or B
if they did they wouldn't b a lot of
money for it I was like so why don't you
think about a way to get all these
people that you're helping start Amazon
stores uh bundled together so that they
become a sellable asset because the
thing is is like just like the event
business that guy had already sold three
of the event venues we know they're
sellable businesses they're very
straightforward they're faceless like
they're relatively turn key same thing
with Amazon stores like they're faceless
like another investor can say okay how
much does it cost what's my you know
what's my yield what's my return going
to be over time okay and like these are
very sellable things and so it takes a
lot less effort to take something that
is already very sellable and just think
how can I do way more of them or how can
I make them bigger rather than try and
take something that inherently has a ton
of uh key man risk isn't recurring um
has a lot of volatility in terms of
acquisition like all of those things
make it not very attractive to a
potential investor real quick if you
want to sell your company or make it
into a sellable business acis.com just
started our Workshop division for
companies that we don't own which is
just walking through the process that we
do to build significantly more valuable
companies at an accelerated Pace we have
it here at our headquarters in Vegas and
so if that sounds interesting you go to
acquisition. comom hit scale and follow
the steps and if you qualify our guys
will be in touch so let's get t for a
second how do you figure this out with
your business so the first thing is is
that is there something that's dependent
on you if anything is dependent on you
for the business it's inherently going
to be significantly less valuable number
one number two is there a component of
your business or of your customers
businesses that's very stickier
recurring so for example gyms micro gyms
for gym launch intrinsically they they
don't get sold very often so there's not
a market for small service-based
facilities like person training Studios
things like that a lot of people don't
want to buy that why because they have
keyman risk at their level too right
whereas if I had if I were helping uh
franchise chains of restaurants like
subway uh you know improve their
profitability then there would be a
clear exit path because franchise that
are existing trade all the time same
thing for accounting firms because they
have high Revenue retention and so
basically if you look at all the
different things that exist in your
business whether it looks at your
customers you look at different service
lines that you offer within your
business and then the overall watching
business itself one of those things
should have some level of Revenue that
sticky and that doesn't require a face
and there there's a lot of other factors
but if I had to like pick a couple those
would be two um that would be really
important that I'd be trying to sus you
know pull apart to figure out what is
the egg and what is the goose and the
easiest way to know if you're right
about this is looking for m&a activity
so mergers and Acquisitions activity for
that type of business so if you look if
you Google like coaching business m&a
ity one it'll show you how much there is
and if you don't find a lot then you'll
be like okay maybe there isn't a big
market for this number one number two if
you do find some what is the difference
between those businesses and my business
and then you'll be able to bridge the
gap and say oh these are the things that
these buyers like not these other things
and then you can start orienting your
effort and your business model around
the things that investors have proven
that they like what I don't want to go
is try and sell a product to a market
that doesn't exist so you have to zoom
all the way back out and think of your
business as a product and an investor or
potential acquir as a customer and so
somebody might listen to this and say
okay well what about gym launch like gym
launch was uh that type of business well
the one thing is that gym launch was
really dangerously close to being a
franchise and so I knew what franchise
laws were and so I purposely like name
system fee by the ways what you need to
be a franchise name as in everybody's
under the same name system everyone use
same systems and there's a fee
Associated and so if you have all three
you have a franchise and if you don't
have a franchise and you're doing all
three of those things you have an
illegal franchise uh which means you're
actually subject to getting sued and all
that kind of stuff and so if you're in
the business of helping people do a
specific type of business you either
have to pick uh name and system with no
fee which most people don't do right but
you could do that you could go name and
fee like CrossFit for example like they
have a name and there's a fee but they
give No Business Systems right or you go
systems in fee but no name right which
was gym launch we didn't tell everyone
that they had to unify under one flag
now one of my potential ideas that I was
thinking about for gym launch in the
future was maybe I will start a
franchise off the side of it and with
the best people I'll plug them into
there now and that will be covered under
franchise law right but the reason that
Jim launch was sellable is that the big
things that everybody needed which was
that keyman was removed so I was no
longer involved in the delivery I was no
longer involved in the ads I had a
leadership team in place right all of
those things the the recurring Revenue
it is recurring Revenue business we did
have relatively good annual retention um
of customers uh and we had multiple
acquisition channels and over time I
grew gym launch to be bigger than me at
the time and here's a here's a nugget
that people don't don't get you see me
now and you see Jim launch right the
thing is is that this Dynamic of the
size of of me and audience you know
influence now uh and JY launch like I am
bigger than gym launch now when I sold
gym launch gy launch was much bigger
than me and so that's the big thing that
people Miss is that like if you're
bigger than the company you will always
be keyman risk for the business now in
that
instance you can sell the goose if you
are bigger but you usually have to sell
a minority and what that means is like
people aren't going to take a risk that
you're going to leave but you're saying
I want to take chips off the table or I
want to either fund an acquisition or I
want to like expand in this way and so
an investor will happily Bet On You by
investing in your business that's what
raising money is fundamentally and so if
I had so like acquisition. comom I
probably can't exit acquisition. comom
nor would I really want to because I'm
associating myself so strongly with it
for such a long period of time but what
I could do is I could raise money off
acquisition. comom and say look at all
of our Holdings and I'm going to sell 5%
or 10% of acquisition. comom at a
monster valuation so that I can either
take chips off the table if I wanted to
or more realistically I would say I want
to go buy this massive company and I
want investors to help me do that and
look out it will add uh value to all the
other Holdings that we have so we'll get
a disproportion return on it right that
me doing that isn't really an exit it's
a transaction or a liquidity event but
it's not me leaving the business like
you look at Beast Industries right like
uh with uh with Jimmy uh Mr Beast he he
raised at the holdco level so that means
that Beast Burger the the the software
he has uh Feasta bles all of them are
under that big thing and so he's not he
can't exit his YouTube channel but he
can sell a portion of it to fund more
growth which is what raising money is
and so he's be able to do that if you
look at um look at Elon right Elon is
inpally linked with the companies that
he has and so his way of doing that is
like they're mostly public companies uh
with the exception of SpaceX and so by
doing that the public participates but
he's not leaving he's the owner of the
business he's still running the business
but he allows other people to
participate in the growth of the company
overall so back to smaller businesses so
I had a a media company um that reached
out to me and was like hey I'm trying to
figure out um like how I structure my
media company to become sellable he had
a number of stars or talent in his in
his kind of like stable right and so if
you're in that business you basically
need to pick one of two directions so
either you get all of the guys in the
stable to support a product so they'd be
like hey this is our hair gel this is
our dip this is our whatever right and
ideally you want that consumable to be a
recurring thing something that and when
I say recurring it doesn't have to be
recurring but it can also be reoccurring
meaning uh if I use hair gel I might not
want to have a subscription for it but
if I when I run out I buy more of the
same thing like I'm not a recurring
subscription for Coca-Cola products but
I do Buy cocaa
stuff on a reoccurring basis and so if
you get enough exposure then people will
buy that right and so the idea here is
that for him either has to have a
product or he sells advertising space
and The Impressions that he's able to
consistently generate become the product
right like so if you're a media company
it's one of those two things you're
either you're either pushing all of that
those Impressions that you're getting
from your stable into one product you
own or you're saying I'm going to let
any advertisers come in as long as it
makes sense for our brand or the brand
of the talent uh to place ads on their
and I'm selling media space itself those
are the two ways that that business
would work now if he wanted to exit that
business he can't exit the Stars the
stars are what generate The Impressions
now if he's not a star he could exit the
business if he has the stable of stars
and he's selling advertising space but
if I were him I would say well I would
rather just have this incubator where I
could just blow up uh products and again
which one's the goose which one's the
eggs in this instance having all this
massive media and Impressions and
whatnot that's the goose and then the
eggs would be the products that we'd
sell through that distribution Now using
the strategy I was saying before he
could raise money by saying I'm going to
sell 10% so I can front all the capital
for this massive launch because if you
have a ton of Impressions is one of the
big issues that a lot of creators have
is that their the their Impressions and
their Fame far surpass their wealth and
so in order for them to accommodate the
demand that they have they'd have to
basically have a ton of money they don't
have to Buy in inventory um and get you
know third like Logistics set up and
like all these other things up front to
do it right right because you want to do
a good job because you can only have one
reputation and so they have to front all
this stuff and if you don't have money
it gets very hard right and so that's
where sometimes having like you're not
exiting your brand before you have the
product you take a tiny bit you give it
to somebody else so they can bet on you
and then you can put that money towards
something that will make everybody more
money now um I'll give you a fourth
example of this so I had an accounting
firm uh kind of like coach consultant
whatever you want to call it reach out
and um he was like hey I'm trying to
think about the ultimate version of my
business now his business was a business
World role it made a lot of sense
because there's a lot of m&a activity in
the accounting space um for a variety of
reasons but one of them is that uh the
book of business is just worth a lot of
money there's usually high gross margins
or net margins in the business uh it's
incredibly recurring and sticky like
people don't normally switch who they're
doing their taxes with year to year to
year and so they have massive ltvs um
the hardest part of the business bus's
acquisition is getting customers but get
keeping customers is actually not too
difficult in that business as long as
you do a good job and so he was like how
do I sell my accounting firm coaching
Consulting thing and I was like well
that's not what you want to sell because
no one's buying that but what people are
buying is accounting firms in glob
together and so the the top version of
your business is having a rollup of 10
20 accounting firms that you can exit
every one or two years and exit for 100
million bucks or whatever and you take
your slice and you say hey I'm the one
who's putting this deal together and I
get 20% get 30% whatever and if you're
thinking about this and you're like well
why would somebody give up that kind of
percentage well here's how it works so
when you buy in bulk right when you go
buy toilet paper or Costco as a consumer
when you buy in bulk you get a discount
like the more you buy the less you pay
per roll that makes sense what's
interesting is that in investing it's a
volume premium so basically the more
profit you have the bigger the company
is the bigger the rollup is the more you
get per and it's because big money is
lazy and so they will pay a premium to
not have to do as many deals because
deals are costly it cost a lot of time a
lot of attention and so if you have to
do a 100 deals versus doing one deal
you'll pay a premium to only have to do
one deal and so if those individual
accounting firms could sell at call it
uh four times earnings on their own
right if they can sell in aggregate
together for call it 12 times earnings
then even if they give up 30% of the 12x
they're still double as good as they
were before and so everybody wins and
the thing is is that I spend a lot of
time trying to find those types of
situations in business where it's like
literally everyone wins it's like if we
work together rather than be competitive
if we can collaborate and I'm telling
you all the guys that I know who make
gobs and gobs and gobs and money like
it's so rare that you're actually
competing against people like I used to
say this in the weight loss world I was
like we're not competing against each
other guys like because I had obviously
a big community of gym owners and we had
tons of gyms that are on the same Market
I was like guys we're competing against
the couch like we're competing against
Netflix we're not competing like we're
competing against chocolate like we're
not we're not competing against each
other right like it's it's only I think
it's like 11% of Americans like have a
gym membership it's still a tiny percent
of people who go to the gym and and
that's have a membership not even use
their membership and so I mean just look
at how many fat people there are like
it's not like it's not like the problem
doesn't exist right and so people get
really obsessed about their competition
rather than just thinking okay how can
we collaborate and we can all get better
because the thing is is that the private
Equity buyer the ultimate person at the
top of this food chain who who uh
Aggregates fragmented
Industries those guys don't think like
small business owners they just think
think oh this is really fragmented I'm
going to roll all these together and
make a much bigger thing they don't care
that you have some sort of animosity cuz
they just remove both Founders who have
egos and say cool these two work well
together and I can see some synergies in
terms of cost and I can get more profit
and own more of the market they just
don't think about it like that and so
all the richest guys I know are just
like like it's so funny because there's
these these these blood feuds that exist
between businesses that are local but
like the guys who you eventually sell to
if you you know succeed and do a good
job with it those guys don't care at all
and they just roll everything together
anyways and so we have this whole
Obsession about like competing but like
the reality is that if you collaborate
you end up making a lot more money I'll
tell you another quick example on this
so there was a dental association that
we were looking really heavily into so
they had like 700 uh dentists that were
in their Association and dentists have
to buy like floss and toothbrushes and
toothpaste and whatever you know other
stuff they need right and so they spend
like 20 30,000 a year on kind of like
consumable products that they have to
use in their practice and so what they
did was they did a co-op in terms of
group buying so they said hey let's all
come together rather than be competitive
let's collaborate and let's buy together
as one and by doing that they're able to
negotiate a big discount in rates and so
the discount that those guys would save
in buying together exceeded the cost of
the annual membership which by the way
brilliant model and so like as long as
you plan on being in business why would
you not want to have a savings that's in
excess of the cost of an association
which if you ever have the opportunity
to do that like I said great model
especially in a niche and so they they
did exactly what I'm talking about is
that he took the top you know 11 of the
of the dentists rolled them up and they
sold it for 120 million but the PE group
damned them was extra smart we were
bidding against them um for the business
was like hey you know what we'll buy
your business too while we're at it
because we'll buy your goose and the
eggs because they all they saw was wait
you have 700 other dentists in here well
that's our that's our egg pipeline for
the next 5 years and so they just was
like cool so we'll do this roll up and
we'll pay you a a premium on your uh
Revenue which was actually recurring to
be in in defense of this business which
is again why it was sellable because
they just knew that they're like okay
well we'll do this rollup but next year
we'll just grab another 20 of them or
another 50 of them and keep add adding
it together and so the thing is is that
the most valuable version of that
business wasn't actually that business
it was the eggs of that business and so
making sure that you understand which is
the goose and which is the eggs for the
business that you're building then I can
Orient my whole business to shoot out as
many of these eggs as I can and by doing
that you have a goose that lays golden
eggs and ideally you hold on that goose
and you pet that little Goose as long as
you can